if you look at the movie joker he's much
more of
a sociopath if you look at the movie
iron man we can argue he might be more
of a psychopath especially the first he
wants he's a bit more cold
towards other people he can be a bit
more data driven
psychopath and sociopath what is the
difference psychopaths are people who
have
less empathy towards others but
far more common than we realize
sociopaths
are people who have done things like
really horrific breaking the law
people who have committed murders people
who are serial murderers those kind of
things
what are your thoughts about what
happened last 12 months with colbit and
the side effects to parents and kids
kovid's been called the great clarifier
this past year with this pandemic
everyone's lost something whether it's a
person or a way of life
our system is kind of broken and
we need to be fixing the system so the
stability of our life can come back as
soon as possible
that's how we cope with the stress
[Music]
my guest today is dr ali matu who is a
psychologist he's also got his own show
called the psych
show he's been the co-host on pbs's
self-evident
and expert on netflix and vox the mind
explained anxiety
hbo's doctor commentaries and a nes
the employables he's been featured all
over the place
his expertise is in treating panic
disorder
social anxiety disorder generalized
anxiety disorder
phobias hair pulling skin picking even
if you are scared of bees he specializes
in that so with that being said
dr ali thank you so much for being a
guest on valuetainment
patrick thank you for having me um i'm
excited to talk to you today
you know it's funny when we were pre us
recording i said listen if this
uh doctor stuff doesn't work out for you
can go into modeling and acting you got
that
unique little look on for yourself man
you got a good look
you go back in time about 30 years and
until
my childhood version of that that that
saved me a lot a lot of years of
hey i think instead of being a doctor
you ought to go into hollywood i think
you're going to be like the omar sharif
type of a guy if you go into it
i don't know anyways listen it's good to
have you on you know i watch your video
uh the one um
on youtube one of our girls brought it
in and she said i think we need to have
him on
and i'm watching i watch it once twice i
mean the way you break it down
all the different personalities of
movies i think that things got over 8
million maybe 10 million views today
and it is a topic that
you know we hear a lot about today but
the area i'd want to focus today with
all these different issues is
how it links up with business and overly
successful people in the world whether
it's business politics
military i'm talking the
obsessive-driven
people at the highest level and i'm
going to bring them some articles here
that talks about how
the link between mental illness and
success but prior to getting into this
i want to know you know if you don't
mind sharing with the audience
how did you wake up one day saying you
know i don't know what i want to be a
psychologist one day how did that
experience take place for you
it didn't happen like that um patrick i
was
um um i didn't know what i wanted
to do with my life growing up i i love
riding my bike
i love playing video games i love
playing street fighter with my brother
um i was i was really into
uh science fiction i love star trek i
love star wars
but uh i don't really have any big
dreams about the future
you know my i grew up in northern
california and
my parents were immigrants and so i i
often got the message like be a doctor
like be be a physician um you know go
go treat some people heal some people
but um
i don't know that didn't really that
side of things didn't click for me
and then i thought okay like all my um
everyone around me is an engineer at
silicon valley maybe i'll go into that i
took
one computer science class patrick and i
i flunked that class man
i was i couldn't think like logically
in terms of like numbers and order and
um i wasn't a good high school student
either i i almost flunked out of high
school i just
didn't really care about anything so i
went to community college
and i was a big slacker i waited till
the last minute to register for classes
one of the only classes left open was
introductory psychology because it's
this
it's a big class like 80 plus people
and it satisfied my my general education
requirements i took it and i never i'll
never forget that first day
is professor gosling and he broke down
all these myths we have about the mind
and the brain and our behavior and
i was hooked i was hooked he gave me a
way
a scientific way of understanding all
the junk that happened in my life
you know and in the world around me how
old were you at this time
18. okay and i just started taking more
of those classes
and um my girlfriend at the time now my
wife
she's like maybe you should major in
this and i'm like what are you gonna
what can i do with psychology that's not
that's not a career um and i i just took
more of those classes i talked to more
of those professors and eventually i
realized hey this is
this is the thing for me i like working
with people
i really like the science i like
understanding things this way maybe
there's something i can do with it
so i became a doctor not the kind of
doctor my parents wanted originally
when i told my dad i was going to get a
phd and go into psychology he said beta
you know what phd means right and i said
no and he said
poor hungry doctor and then he said you
know what md stands for right and i'm
like no dad i'm probably not gonna like
it and he said money doctor
so you sure you want to do this thing
he's come around now
he's come along now but yeah i bet i
mean obviously you're in a different
place today
but yeah that's the story very no now
let me ask you this now
you know when when you hear uh i'm just
writing this note poor my hungry doctor
money doctor when you're when you're
when i hear stories of people that
end up taking a topic and they go a
deeper layer and deeper and deeper and
deeper there's typically a
personal experience something that
happened to them that makes them want to
go
to a place like that i know you
personally had an experience in your
personal life
how much of what happened there with you
and your brother with the influence you
had on you you guys playing video games
together watching star trek with them
when you were a kid
i think it's like nine years older than
you the the age difference
so as an older how much of that had
influence of you wanting to go figure
this thing out
the brain out it had a lot
and a little okay so um
my my brother growing up always
always encouraged my my interests
and he always was exposing me to
different things he was exposing me
to computers he's the one who got me
interested in science fiction
and science fiction is all about these
questions of who we are
what we do and all of that sort of stuff
i think it's because of all those
questions
of science fiction that that i was
interested in psychology
like my brother and i would stay up late
all the time
talking about these movies we saw plenty
of the apes
we would talk about the originals now
i'm not talking about like the new ones
i'm talking about the old school ones
with the makeup that kind of doesn't
look all that great nowadays
but we would talk about those and we're
like why why are they treating people
this way
like where does this inhumanity come
from
you know are we that different than
animals what makes us different
my my brother we'd stay up late talking
about these things over and over
trying to figure things out we talk
about star trek like how can we get
to this better future you know we we
talk about
um we we talk about so many things we
watch the movie alien and we talk about
like why was it so scary
why was it so terrifying so those
conversations
were were he gave me the foundation
for when i got to take psychology that
all these questions that we never got
answers for
boom we got we got now a science that
answers these things
so in that way my brother was incredibly
influential
the other thing though too is
you know i grew up as a very anxious kid
when i was
in kindergarten and went to school for
the first time i had
i didn't realize at the time no one did
around me and my family
but i had selective mutism which means
in certain situations i didn't talk
it's like someone pressed the mute
button on me and
um they put me in esl because they
thought i couldn't speak english
they didn't realize it was anxiety um
that that turned into social anxiety and
when i got to middle school it turned
into depression and eventually in high
school i had a great teacher that helped
me to overcome a lot of my anxiety
but my brother's role was was huge in
that and um
but my my brother you know we didn't
realize at the time but he
he had undiagnosed bipolar disorder and
um when i was in grad school studying
psychology he
ended up taking his own life um we lost
him
and then he had another
impact on me um after he died
um there's two things that i sort of
committed myself to
one is i wanted to help other people
who might be in similar situations as my
brother
um but the other thing is i wanted to
all the lessons he shared with me all
the things he helped me to discover
i wanted to celebrate those things you
know i wanted to
um i wanted to speak out publicly
for all the other kids that were into
all these geeky things
that um at the time weren't that cool
and i wanted to make it cool to love and
discover and understand these things
now we're in a different world now comic
books and all this stuff it's all like
you know it's the thing but um when i
speak up about this kind of stuff i'd
like to think i'm kind of honoring
all those late night discussions we had
uh together
you know when i when i when you say that
to me and i visualize it i think about
it like
here's a guy that's nine years older
than you that doesn't talk to you like
you're a kid it's like the ultimate
older brother he talks you like you're a
you know a uh a grown man which a boy
you want somebody to talk to like you're
grown you want that kind of a respect so
it's it's a great seeing that but as a
person who's a
psychologist who at that time at 25 you
started at 18 did you already have 25
finished schooling or you're not done
yet
uh no no i um
18 i was at community college
20 i transferred to ucla
i got my bachelor's degree after that i
went straight to get my phd i got my phd
at catholic university of america in dc
i was there for about
six years it was supposed to be a
five-year program patrick took me seven
and part of is i had i had a lot of
growing up to do there
but then part of it is also that's when
my brother died too um
so it took me seven years and my last
year my training was in new york
at bellevue hospital and then
in 2012
is when no yeah yeah i think
i think 2012 is when i wrapped up
everything and so i was
i was 30 at the time i think at 30 you
wrap up everything so while you're going
through this
and you're and you're becoming a
psychologist and you have a personal
you know hero of yours a lot of yours
that's going through this
how are you dealing with grief when
you're going through it and now i bet
you know at this age where you are you
probably dealt with a lot of people who
are going through grief and the reason
why i'm asking this question for you
it's so random how
your interview popped up as this week a
couple weeks ago were in hawaii we took
450 of our guys there
and you know we leave hawaii a couple of
our guys decides to stay
one of our guys his name is sebastian
who just had a set of twins with his
wife laila
and another guy named angelo who's one
of our studs coming up quality guy these
guys decide to go and look at one of the
falls well you know
long story short flash floods comes
they get stuck and next thing you know
it leads to
a fall of 200 it's a pretty uh tragic
situation and both of them end up losing
their lives
okay in hawaii what made it very
complicated with this is on one we
didn't find out
about the loss for a week the other one
the body's not been found until today
and it's been several weeks right as
we're going maui's constantly reporting
it and updating it
i watched i spoke to the brother
sebastian's brother nico who have a very
good relation i've known these kids for
13 years they've grown men now both of
them are parents obviously one of them
is not with us
and i watched angelo who passed where
his brother diego
and his family give a speech at one of
the uh uh
uh what do you call it uh funerals that
was being uh hosted in la in
south cal southern california and i
watched the brother talk about it and
the parents gave a speech
and it's a different one you lose your
friend it's a different when you lose
your
father it's a different thing when you
lose a child
watching the parents going through it
mother couldn't even talk to me when
we're speaking on a sunday which i
totally understand
and it's a different one it's a sibling
now that this has
gone you were 25 when this happened he
was 34
2012 you're 30 so add 9 years you're 39
right now it's been 14 years since the
event obviously 14 years
you've been able to heal nothing goes
away permanently that is a scar that
stays for a long time because
it is a brother what could you share
with others who are going through this
that when you're in it what phases does
a person go through and what is the best
methodology to
you know go uh through your healing
process
yeah um well i'm so sorry for your
your team's lost i mean that is that's a
a really tragic situation
and the the thing about grief
and look we got we all got some kind of
grief
right now you know this this past year
with this pandemic we've
many of us have lost people but all of
us have lost a way of life
you know people have lost businesses
people have
lost you know kids are out of school
like some are going back in
but like the kids lost their their
summer
they lost to graduation they lost their
prom they lost all like everyone's lost
something
whether it's a person or a way of life
and
grief is um what it does is it makes
it makes all your emotions supercharged
it makes them incredibly powerful
and the thing about grief is there's no
one emotion that pops up
sometimes there's going to be anger
sometimes there's going to be sadness
sometimes there's going to be anxiety
how am i going to get through my life
without this person in my in my life
sometimes it's it's jealousy sometimes
it's guilt like why didn't i do more
you know it's whatever emotion you're
experiencing
it's normal for a grief and it's going
to be supercharged
it's going to be far more powerful than
than it ever was
uh before you lost this person the thing
about grief
it's not about forgetting the person
it's not about
moving on from the loss it's about
finding some way to be plugged into your
life
right now without getting overwhelmed
by all the emotions that's what it's
about it's about finding
some way to remember without getting
overwhelmed so let me let me tell you
what i went through
um yeah yeah the math is right there my
i was 25 my brother was 34
when he died and i was in the middle of
grad school
and um i i kind of went into to crisis
mode
like i couldn't i couldn't talk about
him i i took all my pictures down
of of us together um when i was around
other people i pretend when i was when i
met new people i pretended like i was an
only child
um because it was wow too overwhelming
for me to think about him to talk about
him
and suicide is one of these forms of
death that um
we often call complicated grief because
it brings up
it it's almost much more like a trauma
like it incredibly
seismically changes your views on
yourself and the world and other people
so for me it was it was many years
of not talking and not thinking about
about him and slowly i was able to share
more of what i was going through
with um with my very close friends
with my girlfriend and then slowly and
slowly with more people i was also
seeing a therapist at that time
with uh with that therapist i was able
to share more
and over time talking about him
became less overwhelming but
that's the thing about about grief is
you know um
not everyone has to go through a
traumatic grief process
but um some people will need to cope
with it
by not talking about the loss some
people
will need to cope with it by talking
about the loss
some people will want to give a speech
some people will want to write a poem
some people will want to put all the
pictures together others will want to
put them all away
there's no right way because there's no
one emotion that pops up
but they're all overwhelming so you got
to do
what you need to do to
to live today and
that's that's the thing about grief is
finding a way
to live with today without getting
overwhelmed by these emotions and with
time
the emotions will become less intense
and then with time
that person can can be more a part of
your memories and more part of your life
right now
you know it's interesting you say that i
i uh i look at how
uh people how we go to funerals at 20
how much of a more impact it has on us
emotionally and you go to a funeral with
somebody who's in their 70s and 80s
and to them it's just a funeral and then
i ask why
why are you like why is it not a big
deal to you
and my dad will say buddy i've been to
hundreds of funerals what are you
talking about like you know
you know how many times i've gone
through it's a part of life i'm just
letting you know my time is coming here
so hopefully you getting ready with
it so it's it's it's funny how life
works not funny it's interesting how
life works that
in our 20s we attend
college graduations weddings in our 30s
we go to kids you know
birthday party all this other stuff and
we hear about divorces your best friend
got a divorce i never thought he would
get a door i never thought she would get
a divorce right
and then once that number turns 40 you
start attending a lot of funerals but
it's different when you start doing that
early on in your 20s and it's somebody
that's that close
i appreciate you sharing that with us
hopefully for the people that uh
experienced that directly you took a lot
away from that i was very very helpful
so let's let's kind of uh transition out
to covet and you brought that up before
i go into this topic i think this is
another issue
important issue to talk about in the
last 12 months you know as a financial
expert
you look at the economy based on what
we're going through right now and you go
back and try to find trends and research
on
how the market reacted when it happened
before we have a covid
pandemic how do we react on the last 10
pandemics before we got a mortgage
but you know crash on bubble we go back
and study it right
for you as a psychologist the number one
topic to study i would guess maybe a top
three topic to study is
the side effects of pandemic to
parents emotionally who are accustomed
to not having the kids eight to five
eight to three they go to school we pick
them up as well as kids
who were accustomed to having that break
from parents and they're around their
peers
now they have to stay home conflict's a
little higher between parents
conflicts a little higher between kids
with parents parents with kids
what do you see the residual effects of
this and
what feedback could you give to parents
to be able to
come back to being normal you know the
whole thing we're going back to normal
what are your thoughts about what
happened last 12 months with colbit
and the side effects to parents and kids
yeah i got i got a lot of thoughts about
that
and um just like you do as a financial
expert you look at
past trends the very first thing i did
about a year ago
when the pandemic was really starting
when things were really starting to shut
down
is looking to see at past pandemics now
we don't have much data on the 1918
flu uh pandemic in terms of mental
health
that's not something people were really
tracking back then but we do have some
data
on sars on the sars outbreak um in
asia that happened um in the early 2000s
and a few things that that um that
stood out from that research is the
psychological
impact of of sars and the disruption of
that
lasted for years particularly a lot of
people who
developed sars experienced a lot of
stigma
a lot of guilt they had a hard time
talking about it there was
the guilt was about did i get other
people sick did i cause other people to
get
ill and die and it was a very hard thing
for people to talk about and we're still
sort of
kind of in the thick of it um there's
some hope with the vaccines you know
there's some hope that we're going to
get this thing under control but who
knows that we got these variants so it's
still kind of up in the air
um so we're still kind of in the middle
of this but one of the things i want
people to know
is there's no vaccine for the
psychological
impact of covid and we're we're gonna
we're learning the long-term
psychological effects too
a lot of folks who have had covid have
difficulty focusing
um they have a hard time with their
attention and memory
we don't know the long-term
psychological impact of it just in terms
of the illness but we also don't know
the long-term psychological impact
of having covid of um of what it's going
to be like on the other end of it
but you talked about parents you talked
about kids
and and even um people who are single
and don't have kids
um one of the biggest things that
happened here with the pandemic
is we lost the most
stabilizing part of our lives we lost
our work we lost
school we lost um seeing
friends and family we lost looking
forward to holidays
whatever holiday you celebrate one of
the things that that it does
is man i can't wait for memorial day my
family we get this big barbecue
it's awesome yeah i can't wait for july
4th i can't wait for the summer thing i
can't wait for the holidays thanksgiving
it's um when you're dealing with a ton
of stuff
a lot of times having something to look
forward to
can get you through some of the grind
and
we lost all of that we lost the
stability
of our day-to-day lives and we lost
the hope of something to look forward to
there's no end
you know patrick i did one one of the
most depressing things i think you can
do right now
uh is something i did a few weeks ago i
went back and i looked at my emails
from march and april man i don't know if
your emails were like mine but a lot of
them were like yeah let's cancel it for
now let's check back in a couple of
weeks when things get back to normal
couple weeks right it never happened
it never happened but that was that was
a lot of the mentality and then we kind
of got into the summer and we're like
yeah we're going to be in this for the
for for a while yeah
so with students what um
we're now getting some pretty good
research on what what happened to them
in 2020 and what we know
um kovit's been called the great
clarifier
and it's clarified a lot of things a lot
of the students that have less resources
they've been impacted by this way more
so um
my one of my cousins is a elementary
school
teacher she teaches kindergarten and
she's telling me ali i got
i got some some of my students um
their family they got three kids they
got one laptop
how how are they all all those kids
supposed to go to school
you know or another um another one of my
families they don't have good access to
wi-fi so they're they're hanging out at
mcdonald's
trying to get on classes so not every
student
has had equal access to online
instruction
so that's problem number one um problem
number two
is um even those who have good access
um they um they might not be dealing
with um you know they might be able to
attend classes and all this stuff
but attention and focus is something
we're seeing
this is some research looking at college
students they've had a real hard time
maintaining focus um being on
zoom classes all day long so i'm on
meetings all day i get it but
i can turn i can turn my my camera off
i can take breaks i'm an adult i got a
little bit more flexibility a lot of
these kids don't
um there's been a lot of research now
coming out about
why why is being online and zoom
or google meet facetime whatever you're
using why is it so overwhelming
and some folks are talking about it's
intimacy overload
you're seeing another person's face like
blown up all day long you know they're
looking at you
all day long we're not designed for that
usually when we hang out
in person or in class at work we look at
each other we take breaks we think about
it we kind of come back
but this this is not really how humans
interact
so we know that attention is really
challenging for a lot of kids on online
instruction
and um that's that's that's the second
big problem is
is attention has been really difficult
for for a lot of kids
and the third thing i want to say is so
we got access problems we have attention
problems the third thing i want to say
is any kid
that was uh struggling before with
school
they've they've really been challenged
here whether it's because of a learning
um a learning disorder or maybe it's
because their anxiety depression
whatever it's whatever is going on
we've seen rates of um there's data now
that shows that over 2020 there was a
big spike
in self-injury among teenagers
so cutting themselves burning themselves
these kind of things
these really spiked we saw substance use
really spiking
uh among teenagers so um
it's it's all of these things and i
think it kind of when we look at it kind
of makes sense
that like for uh when it comes to access
the kids who have the least school was
kind of
the biggest stabilizing force for them
um
and for um in terms of attention we're
not
built for these kind of things we do
much better in an in-person classroom
environment
and when it comes to learning
differences anxiety
depression all of these kind of things
we took away all the peer support
you know being able to see your friends
your friends being able to check in on
you hey man you doing okay you don't
look that great
teachers being able to to check in on
you um
one of the biggest there's this idea of
resiliency which is
your ability to bounce back when you
deal with a setback your ability to
to recover from it that's resiliency and
um one of the biggest things about
resiliency for kids is having
a trusted relationship with an adult who
is not in your family
who's not your mom and dad um and for a
lot of kids
it's teachers it's coaches it's those
kind of folks
and i've talked to a lot of teachers and
coaches i've done workshops for them
this past year
and a lot of them have told me ali i
just don't know
how they're doing i can't tell all these
kids
on their screen they all look the same
and none of them look good
you know i i don't know how they're
doing how am i supposed to tell you know
so it's all of that and don't even get
me started
on being a parent right now and you know
some parents are lucky enough to work
from home
how are you going to work from home
full-time and make sure your kid is in
school
online how are you going to do that and
then and then the parents who've lost
work
um you know people ask me like ali how
do how should we cope
with um with the stress of kovid and i
say
make sure everyone's um who who needs it
is getting unemployment benefits
make sure we can open up as responsibly
and as quickly as possible make sure we
get these vaccines out to everyone
let's get these schools open in a safe
way that's how you deal with the stress
you know i'm not going to teach you a
deep breathing technique
to cope with this our system is kind of
broken
and we need to be fixing the system so
people so the stability of our life can
come back as soon as possible
you know that's that's how we cope with
the stress of kovit yeah
and and let me let me ask you when you
go to school and you went to school for
this for a long time
how often do you guys study the event of
a 1929 market crash to kids 10 20 years
later
the event of a world war ii to kids 10
20 years later the event
of you know kids growing up in a very
poor family sharing the bread with three
other siblings
the side effects of it five ten years
later no wonder
you know the generation that came from
the great depression are so scared
constantly of spending money to they're
savers
and they're so worried because
everything's going to be taken away from
them how much do you guys study that and
if that is the case
what what is the effects of this 10
years from now i'm not really interested
in right now but
is there a way of measuring on what's
going to happen 10 years from now 20
years from now
to kids as well as parents yeah that's a
great question
so um that's that's a real uh
wonderful question so that speaks to
research on trauma
and when we look at trauma there's a lot
that's been studied from
uh world war ii uh there's a lot that's
been studied um
a lot of research that's been studied on
veterans and the vietnam war
and um and refugees and global crises
um so there there's a lot of research we
can bring in from
um from trauma and what we know about
trauma
is it affects adults differently than it
affects
kids one of the ways in which it affects
adults
the the stereotype of trauma is uh is
something like post-traumatic stress
disorder
um someone goes to war they experience
something horrific
they come back they're having flashbacks
of it they're always on guard
always on edge things like that um the
traditional idea is something happens to
you
and now you're experiencing this trauma
and it's it's very much what we think of
as
episodic that this one thing happened
and now you're experiencing this
for kids it's different um and
for for kids um
how trauma impacts them is like i was
saying before
about grief and grief kind of
supercharges your emotions
what happens for trauma and kids is
it does um it does make their emotions
more intense
it makes it easier for the emotions to
to skyrocket and it takes them longer to
calm down
so think of it like this it's like
having a car where you got
a real powerful accelerator and
pretty bad brakes that's kind of what
trauma does to kids
and if if that trauma happens for
a real long period of time it can really
change how they view themselves so
um kids who go through trauma
they might grow up and think that
they're dumb they might think they're
stupid they might think they're unworthy
and people might label it anxiety
depression um these kind of things but
at the heart of it might be a long-term
trauma they experience
so when we look at kids right now first
off
it's not equal not everyone is is
experiencing this in a traumatic way and
i should probably kind of define what
what a trauma is
um you know a trauma
changes your view of yourself of the
world or of other people
the younger the kid is they might not be
able to experience
the all the thoughts that come with it
but what they do experience is the
the very powerful emotions that do come
with it
and um for kids we call we we think
about um
adverse childhood experiences uh which
covid
is one of them getting disrupted from so
covet first
off just the pandemic is adverse
childhood experience
um because now it introduces this this
fear
of getting this virus and especially
kids that are six
seven eight they're already afraid of
germs
and they're already afraid of getting
sick so i'm hearing from a lot of
teachers about
these six seven eight-year-olds going
back to the classroom they're washing
their hands
all the time they're really afraid
they're going way above and beyond
what they need to be doing so that's
kind of one effect we're seeing of this
is just
coveted itself is can be a traumatic
adverse childhood experience
getting disruption from school not being
in school for
a year is a part of this i got a nephew
who is um really scared he's he's in
high school
he's really scared about going back to
school
uh he's he has not been in a large
social environment for over a year now
um he he's terrified of going back
so that is an adverse childhood
experience like how are you
how are you even gonna get your 17.
okay yeah so um how much of that if we
stay on that let's stay on that because
people
being scared to go back to normal uh uh
doc how much of that is
parents okay if you're around oh my gosh
my parents are so scared so maybe i also
got to be scared
how much of that is watching the news oh
my goodness this next variant is going
to
oh this is going to kill even more than
how many how much of that is social
media did you see what happened this
thing is so scary
how much of it is external how much of
it is real how much of it is immediately
your family
to the way they're reacting because i
think a lot of the things is also
some of this can be prevented so from
your experience how much of it is the
news
social and family worried around you i'm
gonna say it's all the above and i'm
gonna add one more which is age
two so patrick you were saying something
earlier like you know you
you um when you have a funeral in your
twenties is different than in your
thirties it's different in
your forties and um and then on and on
so one of the things that covid has done
is uh it's impacted different ages in in
different ways
so you and i we've lived some life you
know
we haven't lived through this kind of
pandemic
and all the all everything that's
happened as a result of it
but we've dealt with some losses we've
dealt with
uncertainty we've lived through some
strange times you know like i i remember
i can tell you exactly everything about
9 11 and the way it it
changed uh changed my world you know
i can tell you about these different
events i can tell you about living
through
the 1989 earthquake and the terror i had
how much i thought i was gonna die in
that moment
like i can tell you about some stuff
that i've lived through and
what i learned as a result of it how i
learned about coping how i learned about
getting through that stuff
kids teenagers are different they've
lived through less
life they've had less exposure to
uncertainty to dealing with this big
periods of
unknown they've had less grief
to deal with that
number one can make it harder
for kids and teenagers to adjust to life
back then then it might be for you and i
and then the other thing patrick is i've
throughout this whole pandemic i've been
the one going to get groceries sometimes
my wife gets groceries too
sometimes we get them delivered but um
the first few times i did that man i was
scared
i was and i was doing a lot of stuff
that now we might find like really silly
like trying to make sure i don't touch
anything you know trying to like
uh be like all on guard and that was
none of us were wearing masks back then
it was
we didn't know what was causing this how
it was being transmitted we didn't know
any of that kind of stuff
but those first few times i went to the
grocery store you know i was terrified
but then as time got on i was getting
less my emotions were less intense i was
learning how to navigate it things like
that
um some kids have just done less during
this time
they've been just more at home right
and so that gets to the family part
you're talking about
is what are the expectations been on for
kids
and there's no right answer here you
know some kids might be more vulnerable
to health related problems and the
families have kept them
at home more some kids might be less
vulnerable and
kids have done more stuff some kids
might have been living in an
area where they've had less exposure to
covid so
you know their lives haven't been as
disrupted so there's a family component
too
there's a environment component there's
a age component
but the other thing you're mentioned is
the role of media as well
you know when when we go through periods
of big uncertainty
it's kind of like an allergic reaction
to anxiety
so when we get allergies our immune
system is responding too much
you know you get exposure to pollen
pollen's a totally
normal thing it shouldn't be doing
anything to us
but when you get exposed to pollen if
you have an allergy your eyes might get
watery
you might get a runny nose you might be
sneezing your immune system
is reacting to something that's normal
and it's thinking
this is something i need to fight when
we get
a lot of uncertainty your mind kind of
reacts the same way
your mind's like i need to think about
this a lot
i need to find a lot of information
about this i need to take
all my attention and focus it and try to
solve this thing
trying to figure it out right that's
what happens
when we're really anxious and we're
dealing with a lot of uncertainty
now let's play this out if this is
happening to you
and your mind's like get more
information learn more about it
worry more about it try to solve this
problem and you're going
to a lot of new sites or
you're looking up really horrible things
like you know you go to google and you
and you look up you know worse side
effects of covid
unknown side effects of kovid like how
to know if you
secretly have covid but don't have
symptoms you know you look up that stuff
you're gonna find yeah
really scary wild whacky corners of the
internet that's just like the movie if
you remember the movie that was trending
was contagion you remember the movie
contagious oh yeah
everybody go watch it it's identical
yeah everybody was like oh my gosh look
what's going on i mean the
the effect of it had to to you know
make it even exaggerate the crisis that
we had not downplaying the crisis but it
exist
so so let me ask you this question so so
panic disorder social anxiety disorder
hair pulling disorder phobias you know
skin picking
you know tourette's uh take bipolar all
of these things that you deal with
how much of this all these things that
you know folks go through
i've gone through panic anxiety myself
uh
having lived in a war in iran 10 years
that can do a number on you refugee camp
parents divorce
army you come into a new place you don't
speak english all you take is esl a lot
of those things can have an impact on
your life
but uh how much of us having
or somebody being diagnosed with bipolar
or schizo or a ton of panic
a ton of anxiety a certain phobia that
you have
how much of that doc is your dna
okay like i have three kids they're all
different so not saying dna as in genes
i just call it dna i don't know if
that's the right word or not or let's
say
wiring your individual wiring that has
nothing to do with your parents
you have your own wiring how much of it
is that how much of it is
genes how much of it is your experiences
that you're personally going to
experience
and how much of it is your environment
that leads to you
having bipolar anxiety panic schizo any
of this stuff what would you say to that
yeah i wish i had a um a universal
answer
that would fit all the things you just
mentioned
um but it really depends on the type of
problem
we're talking about so let me break out
some of the things that you mentioned we
mentioned bipolar disorder so bipolar
disorder
is something that is much more genetic
what that means is it tends to run
in families and i've seen that i can
trace it back
once we knew that this is what my
brother was dealing with it was like oh
my gosh
this is what so-and-so struggles with
this is what's
another relative experience is we see
the connection in our family how it's
been sort of passed along
there's other things too that that can
run in families like um
adhd attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder can run in families
ticks and tourettes can run in families
i once had a patient
patrick this is a young teen
who we just diagnosed him as having
tourettes and the dad said i don't know
where he gets this because i said you
know this runs in families it can be
genetic
i have no idea how how he gets this and
the mom of the child turned to the dad
and said are you kidding me you have a
blinking tick
and he's like i've got a blinking tick
he's like yeah you've had it the whole
life you know
so like some of these things run in
families you don't even know you have it
you might not know what you have you
might you know you look i mean patrick
you and i
like when we were kids how much were
people talking about mental health
nobody was nobody was yeah nobody was
talking about these things you know
that child is a problem child they don't
listen
you know but now we might be like oh man
that kid
that kid's really depressed or that kid
it's got
adhd you know we see things in a
different way now my brother when he was
growing up
in the 70s 80s bipolar disorder wasn't
on anyone's radar no one's radar you
know
so you go back a few generations and
people just didn't see things this way
especially not in schools like i'll give
you an example autism
autism is a it's a a really complicated
problem that has um it has there's a lot
of biology involved and
we're not 100 sure what the cause is but
we do know that a lot of biology is
involved
here nowadays every pediatrician
at certain ages does screenings in the
united states i can't speak to globally
but in the united states every
pediatrician does screening
for autism to make sure that we're
catching these kids
early that's because of a lot of adverse
advocacy
from parents it's because of a lot of
research from scientists
that's in place now you know we try to
catch these things
earlier but you just go back a few
decades
no one was looking at this stuff so part
of it
is that we're seeing things a little bit
differently now
and you go back a few generations and
um maybe someone was oh yeah you know
grandpa
grandpa drank a lot um maybe grandpa was
drinking a lot because
he was he was really anxious you know we
don't know
or maybe grandpa's drinking a lot
because he's a refugee
he went through major trauma you know he
escaped a war
um but no one thought of it as trauma we
used to think a long time ago of
shell shock that soldiers would go
through this shell shock
and um you know like our our
understandings
evolved so some of these things run
through families but
we didn't we don't see them as as as
mental health problems we don't see them
as mental illness
so things like bipolar things like
schizophrenia you mentioned
schizophrenia
we know there's a biological component
but we also think there might be an
environmental component
autism we know that's a big biological
component but some of the
other things you mentioned about anxiety
and
and depression the way i think about
that
is some people are born with a
temperament and what do i mean by temper
i don't mean like yelling and screaming
temperament temperament i mean
how intensely you feel different
emotions
[Music]
most of that is biological
doesn't mean you can blame mom or dad
but it does mean the unique dna you got
that's led to your temperament and so
what do i mean by that
you know um some people are born with a
volume turned up on anxiety
some people are turned with the volume
um down some people were born with the
volume turned down on anxiety and i
think we've all seen those kind of
people
you know i'm kind of uh i'm a like
medium high is my level and so i'm less
likely
to do my when my friends are like hey
let's go snowboarding i'm like i don't
know if i want to do that
because where my head goes is i'm going
to fall and break my leg like that's
just where my head
is but we all know people with anxiety
turned way down
they're the first one to get on that
board they're the first one to hit that
like extreme
level mount you know like some
people the daredevils in our life
they're
probably have very low levels of
of anxiety and the people who are really
risk
averse maybe you worked with some of
these financial investors and they're
they're highly averse to risk you know
they think through things
a lot um maybe they're bored maybe their
temperament is a little bit higher
um for anxiety so and that's true of
anger it's true of sadness it's true of
happiness too
we're all born with the range and for
some of us is high for some of us is low
you know
so part of that is just the dna wiring
that we've got
but then we've got the environment
you know some of us go through really
horrible experiences
some of us have an easier time
and that's not to say that that leads to
the problems
but it's also leads to how we learn to
cope with them
you know some of us might go through
tough stuff and we
we learn really quickly how to deal with
those really horrible
emotions we learn really quickly how to
cope with this kind of stress
and some of us aren't able to so it it's
a complex
connection between our dna our wiring
our environment what we learn from our
family our culture
culture is a big part of it um what
emotions
are allowed in the culture what aren't
how people cope with these things and
then what happens
when you learn how to deal well with the
culture but then
now you're put into a different place
where like the things you you learn
you can't easily do you know um so
it's it's all of these things it's
biology it's culture it's what you learn
it's the difficult things you go through
it's it's it's all of that
and when we talk about anxiety all the
folks i've treated
you know um some people got more of the
biology and they had less of the
environment stuff
some people had like no biology
environment stuff but they went through
some really tough things
you know um it's a little bit different
for each person
i got very helpful right then we're
going to come back to it based on the
the conversation questions i'm going to
ask you here two books
that i read that changed the way i
looked at hypomanic so
think about manic hypomanic so one of
them was a book written by
uh uh uh nasir rohemi
one of them was written by nasser rahami
which
is first-rate madness the other one was
hypomanic edge
and on this one it says uh the subtitle
is uncovering the link
between leadership and mental illness
okay
that's this one new york times
bestseller the other one is hypomanic
edge the link between a little craziness
and a lot of success in america okay so
let's talk about the hypomanic one
in the hypomanic book like page 15 or
something
it says given how radically different
mania and haplomanic is it is perhaps
surprising that then
sorry so it goes all the way down to
saying there's certain criterias
that people have one of these things
that they're
manic or hyper hypomanic inflated
self-esteem or grand duosity you know
like you're thinking so highly of
yourself
decreased need for sleep they feel like
they don't need to get a lot of sleep
three four five hours of sleep
everybody's like how the hell do you do
that more talkative than usual
or pressure to keep talking flight of
ideas or subjective experience that
thoughts are
racing distractibility attention too
easily drawn to
unimportant or irrelevant external
stimuli like why are you paying
attention to that butterfly
it's got nothing to do with your life
increasing goal directed
activity either socially at work
sexually
it's just higher than usual excessive
involvement and pleasurable
activities that have high potential for
painful consequences
engaging in unrestrained buying spree
sexual
discretions or foolish business business
investments so
and then nasir talks about in a
completely different way in a similar
way
where he says we have to understand that
there's benefits
of illness like bipolar disorder and
depression that can be good to have in a
leader
and he says nations have made it through
difficult times throughout history
because they're mentally ill leaders
and last one it says recognizing that
mental illness has its good ideas as a
step
toward breaking the stigma toward it
okay so
you have this heart put put a church
hill
they talk about churchill they like they
talk about alexander hamilton
bill clinton a trump a jfk
you know there's a lot of different
issues that these folks have experienced
i mean john f kennedy has one of the
most difficult fathers
to have as a father who was hard
charging right what benefits
are there in business to some folks hey
that do have mental disorders that
maybe if we read the book we're like
they have issues but when it comes down
to business leadership military they
tend to excel
yeah um you speak about um
hypomania there which is a part of um of
bipolar disorder
and um there's a another book by
a psychologist who actually has bipolar
disorder herself her name is k
redford jamison i think the book is
called exuberance
but one of the things that she talks
about is
how mental illness gives you a different
perspective you know and
this is one of the things i've learned
in my career
is um i'm i'm taking this from
from another psychologist so this is not
some amazing words i came up with but
they've
always stuck with me the world needs all
types of brains
you know teams need different types of
brains
organizations need different types of
brain countries need different types of
brains
what i mean by that is the most
dangerous
thing in a team is when everyone's
thinking the same way
you mentioned kennedy the bay of pigs
invasion
was a complete disaster it was a
complete
disaster because of something called
groupthink
where it wasn't allowed
for people to express different points
of views
that might challenge the leader we saw
this with the space shuttle
um um challenger disaster as well
it was the same thing there was people
saying this
ship we sh there's a flaw here we need
to look at it
we should not be flying this thing and
there's other people saying
shut up we're going to move forward with
this so
the most the most important thing for
any
business is to have a team
where we've made it safe for people to
share
different points of view and when you
have
a mental illness you are seeing the
world in a different way
for good and for bad and what i mean by
for bad is you're you're experiencing
things that might
cause you distress in your life they
might make it hard for you to live your
life
so when you have uh let's let's talk
about
hypomania for example um yeah you might
be talking
um excessively you might have that
distractibility you're bouncing around
from
from different ideas um you might be
um ordering too much uh
too much shopping you might be doing a
lot of that excessive pleasure seeking
you're also seeing things very
differently and
we need to mix to celebrate those
different perspectives
and make it okay for people to
to be openly um have anxiety
have depression have hypomania have
um schizophrenia we need to
we need to make it okay to and
not just okay but celebrate these
different ways of seeing things
we always want to make sure that people
are getting the help that they need i
mean
schizophrenia is um one of the the
biggest common symptoms of it is just
real confusion about what's happening
around you and at the same time
it gives you a drastically different
view
of the world and there is massive value
in that you know um i had a professor
once who
said that they believe that
adhd has survived in our gene pool for
so long
because these are exactly the kind of
people that you want to have
on guard for your tribe when you were
when you were threatened by enemies
because they're the first ones to turn
and look at different sounds and
distractions in the environment
they will be the first ones to spot
potential threats
you know they're always so quick to
react to different things happening
to you and that always stuck with me
because i thought huh what if we focus
less
on the problems that these things cause
and a little bit more on the benefits
you mentioned up top
the show i did a e the employables
and that show we worked with a lot of
people who have
autism and who have um tourette's
to help them understand yeah you got
these things
and it's your responsibility to learn
how to cope with them at the same time
you got a lot of gifts as well and you
have a different way of seeing
things and how can we help you to really
own those differences so that you can
really make a big difference
in in the organizations you serve you
know i'm a big
i'm a huge believer in that um
you know you when you when you got
you're hiring someone to be an air
traffic controller
you want someone who's going to be a
little bit more conservative and someone
who's going to be a little bit more
anxious
you know there's there's certain jobs
that you definitely
want people who have a way of seeing
things
if you're doing some quality assurance
stuff you want someone
who who might think a little bit more
the way you like someone who has autism
does
you know people who don't have autism
they're very
biased towards verbal and social
behavior
people who have autism are much more
biased towards
logic and visual
information people who have autism
can do so much better at
problems related to logic so quality
assurance coding these kind of things
um they might be able to see things that
someone who's more
the term is neurotypical someone who's
neurotypical they wouldn't see those
things
or they'd have a lot of problems with
them so absolutely i
agree with uh with that that idea that
um
organizations need a diversity of brains
to to be able to to perform their best
that's that's where you get the real
creativity patrick it's
yeah it's yeah i mean i read this book
i'm like wait what
you know inflated self-esteem decreased
need for sleep more talkative than usual
flight of ideas or subjective experience
that thoughts
are racing distractibility increasing
goal directed activities excessive
involvement pleasurable activities that
have a high potential painful
consequences like
the the idea of willing to kind of
play on the you know edge and hey i'm
gonna take a little bit more risk and
who cares i know there's some risk
involved in it but what if we go out
there and pull this thing off
um i was talking to one of my guys one
time i said you know what i don't worry
about you when
everything is good everything is bad
when everything is bad i don't worry
about you because
you're very good when it's chaos and
havoc
i worry about you when everything is
good because when everything is good
you somehow someway have a tendency of
creating havoc
and chaos because that's your comfort
zone you like to have
chaos so you don't know when everything
is like oh my gosh things are going too
good i mean something's
probably about to fall apart and
someone's going to break apart i need
some more crisis in my life and
you you tend to create it but i've seen
a lot of trends with this
on folks who win in business that
they're wired
slightly different and the world may
look at them and say this person is a
psychopath
sociopath this person's got problems but
in reality
they use those same abilities to win in
business so having said that going into
psychopath and sociopath one what is the
difference and two
why do so many of them make it to the
top of politics business
everything yeah um
psychopaths or psychopathy it's it's
people who have um less empathy towards
others and that that might sound scary
at first
but um it's what research has shown is
it's um far more common than we realize
and so um it's it's when
other people might experience um
a lot of intense emotions they might
experience
a lot less emotions um they're less
um uh they're less reactive
to things and someone who has more
psychopathy um psychopathic term
they're the kind of people who make
great scientists
great business leaders
and the reason for that these are all
you know these are a lot of people who
are in
in financial industry the reason for
that
is they're making decisions that are a
lot less personal
they're making decisions that are a lot
less emotional they're
looking at the data they're looking at
the trends
and they're letting they're letting that
sort of guide their decision making
there's a this well-known story about uh
in
in this whole world about um a
neuroscientist who was studying
um psychopaths and in the process of
studying them
realized that he himself
fit the category of this and
that kind of sparked a lot of the
conversation around well
you know this is something you want in a
scientist you want someone
who is very objective not taking things
personally but
looking at the data and letting the data
guide things
sociopaths are are people who
have have done things like really
horrific breaking the law
it's more of a legal term and it's um
people who have committed murders people
who are serial murderers those kind of
things
that's that's more of a sociopath so um
if you look at the movie um if you look
at the movie joker
uh he's he's much more of a
sociopath um if you look at the movie
um iron man we can argue he might be
more
of a psychopath he's he's especially the
first few ones he's uh
he's a bit more cold towards other
people um
he's he can be a bit more um
a bit more data driven and i'll get in
trouble with this with all the marvel
fans because they're like what are you
talking about
he's a guy who kind of pulls us out of
all this infinity war and all that stuff
i know i know i'm i'm making big
generalizations here
how about ben affleck in uh in uh uh in
the accountant
i don't think i've seen that i haven't
you've gotta be haven't seen the
accountant no oh my god
you listen you gotta watch that this
week it's a
ridiculous movie read especially for
somebody who's in the space
interesting so the joker sociopath
uh uh iron man psychopath
because he didn't really care much about
not this does the idea of psychopath
help when a person is in business
because they don't really feel
and understand the idea of rejecting an
idea i don't understand rejection
you don't think i can do it it doesn't
bother me is that is that the benefit in
the world of business
so it's it's a bit more that you can
make
you can make decisions less
based on your emotions related to other
people
so look like if you if you're at a
startup
um you are your idea is not taking off
and um you got you got only so much
funding right
you got a million dollars left um and
your idea is not working
maybe you decide that hey you know what
i'm gonna lay off
half the team because for the larger
business
we need to cut down our expenses if we
got a shot at making this work right
so people who are who have more
psychopathy
are able to make that decision easier
than someone who is going to be
really struggling with that like i i
can't do it i can't
i can't let these people go and then the
whole business might
might completely die out because you can
make that tough call
that might actually hurt some people but
be better for the larger team
you know that's the idea right there
what we were talking about a little bit
before
and i think presidents are a good
example of this is um
it is a bit more ego and a bit more
of uh what i'd call like a healthy
narcissism
and self-confidence in yourself um
that is what what allows a lot of
presidents
to to get to that place you know i just
finished um
reading obama's memoir man that is a
long book
um my gosh um it was really long i
didn't
i did an audio book um but it's like 38
hours
i think it's 38 hours or 36 hours yeah
i i had to wash a lot of dishes to
finish that book
um but you know the thing that stuck out
to me is how much his story
is so similar to every other president
memoir i've read
you know they all have this sense of
like when other people are telling them
you can't do this
they're saying no i can yeah i can i can
totally do this like this time's going
to be different
you watch right that sense of
self-confidence
in yourself of thinking highly of
yourself that you can do things that
other people might not be able to do
whether you want to call that ego you
want to call that self-confidence you
want to call that narcissism
everyone who's reached the top of
um of their different industries has a
good
dose of that a healthy dose of that and
what i mean by a healthy dose of that
is they also have to know their
weaknesses too
like people who might have too much
self-confidence might not realize
where they need to delegate to other
people where they need to get
input from other people all of that kind
of stuff
but anyone who's reached the top here
has a
has a very high sense of confidence in
themselves
you know a completely different uh topic
is on
insecurity uh uh you know i was having a
conversation with a friend of mine
12 years ago and we were at pebble beach
and we were looking at everybody that
was winning at this one event that we
were at
everybody was extremely confident and
insecure at the same time
very weird how those two go together
here here you got a guy or gal standing
on stage and let me tell you
but they have this deep rooted two or
three insecurities that we because we
were
friends we knew these deep insecurities
drove the hell out of them
to go win at the highest level we're
like wait a minute how do your
insecurities drive you so what would you
say about people's insecurities
as a driver yeah it's it's a it's a
great question
and um you know the the term imposter
syndrome gets tossed around a lot
now nowadays um this idea that
um people are gonna figure out i don't
really belong here
um i don't they're gonna figure out i
don't really fit they're gonna figure
out i'm a fraud that kind of stuff
i think that drives a lot of people uh
as well
um as some of these insecurities these
chips on their shoulder you know
that that kid that that that depressed
anxious kid who i was in in middle
school
um part of that is still there you know
like
when you said uh if this doesn't work
out maybe you should go
hollywood or be a model like that kid in
me was like
what are you talking about you know like
have you looked
in the mirror right um so like
by the way fyi i figured out who you
look like it's this guy named riz ahmed
i don't know if you know who he is oh
yeah i know
he's amazing i i love um i get that
um i get rids and i go i also get taiko
watiti
uh um this guy who directed uh he's
directed a bunch of movies um
so i'm cool with that i i like race i'm
i'm a big
big fan of his work rooting for him at
the oscars this year
um so when we're talking about
insecurities and and we talk about
um um we talk about imposter syndrome
stuff too
um there's a fine line
between when it's helping you and when
it's hurting you and sometimes it might
be doing
both at once you know your your
insecurities about
um your finances about
um about your weight about your
your health about your achievements
they can be the things that both are
motivating you to do
more to put in that extra work to
to try harder to read more of those
books to talk to more of those people
and they can also be those things that
keep you up at night that make you
second-guess
yourself that make you think you're
you're not good enough you're not
um you haven't done enough and so
we have to sort of um
anyone who's going to be good in in the
business space
you got to understand yourself you got
to understand
um you know what am i really good at
like what am i honestly good at
like patrick i knew um when your team
reached
out for this interview i'm not i'm not
the kind of guy who's like
going to be sweating about this because
i know this is something i do well
like talking to other people having a
conversation
explaining things using analogies i know
this is something that i do well but if
you ask me
to design an experiment with the best
scientific methods
come up with the best statistics to make
sure that
all this stuff is like 100 like
up to code it's not my strength that's
not
that's not what i'm good at you know so
we got to know our strengths and
weaknesses
and then we gotta get good i would say
my biggest advice to anyone who
wants to succeed in business you gotta
get good
at getting feedback from other people
and
getting critical feedback at
learning from your mentors at talking to
people
who are much better than you at the
thing you want to get
good at and getting that critical
feedback
one of the the things that i think as as
a parent now
and as as someone who you know i was
trained as a child clinical psychologist
so my first part of my career i mostly
work with kids teenagers young adults
um the the 16 to kind of 25 year old
like they're my they're my favorite
group to work with
and the thing i saw that really that
these people
really struggled with is failure
learning from failure and getting
feedback like we got to make it
okay as a society
to get critical feedback the thing we
shouldn't be worshipping
is success we shouldn't be worshipping
all these like like elite athletes
and like what they've achieved we
shouldn't be worshipping
all the business leaders and everything
that they've they've accomplished here
what we should look at is all these
leaders all these people that we look up
to
where do they fail how do they learn
from that how did they improve
the obama book i was just mentioning man
this guy lost so many elections
before before like things took off like
but what he did is he
learned from them he got feedback what
am i doing right what am i doing wrong
and this is where it connects to
insecurities
um your insecurities can be a great
driver
if you know what your real strengths are
you know your real weaknesses
and you got the guts to get feedback
from other people
you know and and that's where i would
say insecurities can be a big problem
is if they keep you from asking those
tough questions if i said like
patrick you've seen a lot of my videos
man tell me what do you like
but what i want to know more is like
what did you not like you know
is my production quality are they too
long am i going on and on about this
like what can i do to get better you've
got
this super successful youtube channel
you know like
like tell me how i can improve right i
need to be able to have the guts
to go into that vulnerable place where
i'm getting your feedback
by the way i've enjoyed this a lot and
and whether you're a executive
salesperson an entrepreneur or just
anybody that's just watching this a
parent a
17 year old kid that's gone through
copenhagen and you're trying to figure
yourself out
uh we touched so many different angles
in this uh interview together extremely
helpful
i learned a lot from you brother i
appreciate your time
uh what uh what people if you don't know
guys he's got a show
called the psych show and it's a youtube
channel if you haven't subscribed to it
yet
we're gonna put the link below it's
gonna be all over the place so you can
see what it looks like and if you're
wondering
when i said he looks like you know uh uh
uh
he looks like rhys i want you guys
editor please put the picture right next
to us make the comparison to rizz
because
i think if you didn't do what you did
here you would absolutely be a hollywood
star you got to look for it
but uh once again brother thank you for
your time appreciate you coming and
being a guest on value team and i really
enjoyed it
yeah i want to thank you for making this
space for us to talk about
all of these things um that's why i
wanted to come on here i know you do
a thorough job with with your interviews
and
i'm never going to turn down an
opportunity to really talk about mental
health
to celebrate these things so i
appreciate you making the space
god knows we need to talk about this
more today we need to talk about this
issue more today once again
thank you interesting interview lots of
topics covet reaction anxiety bipolar
hypomanic the link between insecurity
and success
so many different topics i want to know
what you took away from it comment below
and if you enjoyed this interview i
think you will enjoy the interview i did
with dr jordan peterson in front of 7
000 people if you've never seen this
before it's the same exact event that i
interviewed jordan peterson
the late kobe bryant as well as
president bush click over here to watch
that interview take care everybody
bye-bye